would it be all right if I told you all
about my first
kiss sounds like it would be all right
so I'm from a small town in the United
States and I was working at one of the
local spots a job that required me to be
in person a Frontline job so I'm there
behind the counter the person I really
like they come in we have a great
conversation and I know this because it
with a
kiss perhaps that kiss that day though
was the only good thing about the job
the work itself was really really hard
most Frontline work is and you know this
if you drive for Uber oryt or if you
work as a Brie at
Starbucks today I spend all my time
working with some of the world's largest
companies companies with tens of
thousands of Frontline workers nearly
three billion of us around the world do
this work and it's my mission to make
make that job as good as possible it
just doesn't take much research to
realize why we need to improve this job
80% of Frontline workers face some form
of incivility in
2023 and that's translated into anger
40% of the global adult Workforce is mad
at work now I'm not a psychologist but I
can't imagine it's good when half of the
adults are angry at their job and that
number has doubled from before
Co I just don't think this has to be the
case I think Frontline jobs can be great
careers let's talk about how to make
that
happen for me it starts at the top CEOs
don't know what the Frontline job is
like and they have got to figure it out
right now I'm not sure if any of you
have seen the show Undercover Boss it
was it was hot at least in the United
States for a little while very simple
premise Executives leave their corner
office they spend some time on the front
line and and they're always really
really shocked what they find and you
might say Adrien of course they're
shocked it's reality TV it's American
reality TV that is the best of the
best these Executives they went to
Harvard Business School that's HBS
Harvard Business School they have big
offices they know what the job is like
you might be shocked to find CEOs spend
just 6% of their working hours with the
front line they spend 70% of their time
in meeting
I just don't believe you can actually
understand the job when you spend just a
few days a year seeing it what I would
like to see instead I would like to see
a CEO spend 30 days straight that's just
8% of the Year tons of time still for
your meetings 30 days straight doing one
shift every single day and then spend
only the money you make from that shift
with no
backups after this 30 days ask
yourself can I make it what I want this
job to my kids career I think through
this experience you'll be a lot more
attuned to the problems with the job and
you'll also very importantly realize
your own employees have a lot of good
ideas on how to make the job better and
before I talk about those ideas let's
address the elephant in the room for
everyone that's
pay wages matter and it drives me crazy
that some CEOs and the Fortune 500 are
making $70,000 a day and it would make
their it would take their own employees
$150 years to make what they make in one
year there's a word for this it's pay in
equity and it's wrong and it frustrates
me and I could talk about this for hours
believe me afterwards let's let's go
talk about it but but today I want to
share something from our own research
we've surveyed tens of thousands of
Frontline workers around the
globe why do they say they quit their
own job they say it has to do a lot more
with emotional needs than just pay alone
a really good example is a high desire
for some shift
flexibility and when I bring this up
with Executives I often hear shift
flexibility for Frontline workers that
can't happen their job requires them to
be in person way too expensive I don't
know if that's true one company I work
with for a very long time they did some
super dramatic things so folks buckle up
those seat belts these are some crazy
changes that they made hold on here so
the first thing they did they gave their
workers a 10-minute buffer in the
morning so they could drop their kids
off on time I know crazy right like my
mind was blown when this this came up as
an idea but it gets crazier the second
thing they did they got rid of their
point system essentially there's an
attendance policy system at most
manufacturing plants still around the
world if you're late to work or don't
show up get a little check mark by your
name just like in kindergart and it's
public people can see this they said
let's get rid of that good
idea the last thing they did the third
thing they did and this is like the
moonshot idea like next in AI sort of
thing the thing they decided to do they
let their
workers end their shifts on
time you work 9 to 5 you get to leave at
5: it's crazy stuff obviously I'm
kidding like this is clearly a joke but
these small changes very few companies
are doing it and the results speak for
themselves as some of these plants
turnover is down 50% there's a 40%
reduction in overtime hours and there's
actually more perfect attendance than
ever another company we worked with for
a long time we come in and we see people
are getting hurt a lot like physically
injured on the job and we quickly
realize the personal protective gear
that's issued to employees it's made for
only one body type you can probably get
yes what body type it's the white male
body type and we say that's not very
smart so let's get safety gear that fits
multiple body types and that along with
a couple other very small changes safety
incidents were down
40% and when I bring these examples to
Executives they often say that makes a
ton of sense like I'm very compelled by
this but isn't this turning into a If
You Give a Mouse a Cookie situation and
I would say one like CEO great reference
incredible children's book go back and
read it if you haven't read it recently
and and two and very importantly yes it
is turning into that situation you can
give your employees the full
cookie I've talked to hundreds thousands
of workers over the last couple years
and what do the workers say themselves
that they need to be
successful they say they need a clean
bathroom they need safety gear that fits
they need a little time to eat
lunch and they need a living
wage and when I talk to Executives I
often hear well we can give a but we
can't give B if we give B our business
is going to
implode I'm sorry if your business is
going to implode because you provide
workers I don't know a clean bathroom
and a living wage it's time to look at
your business bottle again and and
yeah and I'm not saying this to ding
CEOs I'm not saying this to ding
companies I'm saying this because I have
worked with organizations to change
their business model it is very possible
and when you make these changes what
actually happens it pays for itself it
pays for itself in less overtime less
turnover and happier and much more
engaged employees and that's good for
your people CEO that's also very good
for your
business there's another thing that
matters to me a lot I hope it matters to
all of you as well
it's how we treat each
other now I'm not saying you have to
wander the world as your own version of
the world's best Optimist Ted
lasso you can do that that would be
great more teds in the World Net
positive for the world you're allowed to
be mad if the brand provides you a bad
experience that is okay but before you
get mad at the worker in front of you I
want you to ask yourself why did this
breakdown and experience happen because
I think these experiences they go bad
from decisions way above workers pay
grade let me let me talk a little about
how workers themselves are mandated to
treat all of us as customers there are
these handbooks workers are given on day
one and they are filled with rules that
employees must follow to provide us good
customer service let me give you some
examples at some fast food
chains employees are told if they see
somebody sitting by themselves for 10
minutes or so to go check in on them as
some retail stores
you must solemnly this is written down
solemnly swear if someone comes within
10t of you you'll make eye contact
you'll smile at them you'll ask if you
can help with
anything and my favorite rules I've seen
recently some Airlines they mandate how
to treat your dog as a customer on a
plane and this includes all types of
dogs big small barking anxious There are
rules the flight attendant must follow
I've seen this stuff I've asked workers
about it asked about it on Reddit a
couple weeks ago and on Reddit the front
line comes out in full force so go have
a look after
this the point is somebody took the time
to write down these rules and mandated
the employees follow
them we also can follow a set of rules
and what I will call the handbook of
humanity and I know we can follow these
rules let let me tell you why there's
this restaurant called the restaurant of
mistaken orders I'm not sure if you've
heard of it it's based in Tokyo Japan
almost all the employees there have
dementia it's a really interesting idea
in a country where one in five or so
people will be affected by Dementia in
the next couple years the restaurant is
trying to raise awareness and I might be
leading the witness just a bit here at
the restaurant of mistaken orders 40% of
orders are delivered incorrectly you get
the wrong
food 99% of people have a really good
experience at this restaurant the other
1% filled out the survey wrong you know
the thing is you might say Adrian
obviously the restaurant of mistaken
orders people know the rules they know
what to expect yeah that's true and you
know what the rules in the handbook of
humanity are also written down they're
very clear for everyone to follow rule
number one if I have to spell it out for
everyone and I will don't worry like I'm
not going to leave you
hanging number one don't be a
jerk don't be a jerk when your specialty
latte takes a bit too long to brew and
don't be a jerk when your flight is
delayed and the gay agent has to tell
you because of the thunderstorm no gate
agents cannot control the weather
contrary to popular
belief don't be a jerk and be a good
human the handbook of humanity holds in
all of these
situations there's one more group of
people I want to talk to you today
before I end my
time what is my advice for the three
billion of us that do Frontline work
what can Frontline workers themselves do
to make their experience
better I've honestly thought about this
for a very long time and I don't think
Frontline workers need to do
anything all I have to say to the three
billion Frontline workers that show up
every day in person and that includes
before covid during covid and even today
all I have to say and all the CEO of
these companies should be saying is a
massive massive thank
you you should not have to ask for basic
human decency comfortable working
conditions and a living
wage and you should expect all of us as
Leaders of companies all of us as
customers you interact with all of us
just as basic humans to do
better and I am so confident we can do
better let's do
better thank you very
much